[Música]
l
ah
[Música]
las estadísticas en eeuu dicen que 1
cada 59 personas tiene autismo
hay alguien en la sala con autismo
hay alguien en la sala que conozca a
alguien con autismo
si esta estadística la llevamos a un
colegio en dos divisiones de 30 alumnos
habría una persona con autismo
si eso lo llevamos a la totalidad del
colegio
que hay 16 niveles desde jardín infantes
hasta el secundario veríamos que 16
chicos con autismo eso implica que hay
16 familias involucradas directamente
con el autismo
y todo el resto del colegio va a estar
involucrado indirectamente con el
autismo
porque a cada chico va a haber que
explicarles que chicos que quizás
los ven distintos pero son tan personas
como ellos que hay cosas que les
molestan como los ruidos los tumultos de
gente las luces
pero van a tener que compartir recreos
cumpleaños invitarlos a la casa a jugar
incluirnos y no apartarlos
esto es para que vean el impacto del
autismo en la sociedad
todos deberíamos saber detectar los
primeros síntomas del autismo porque en
cuanto antes se detecte y se estimule
cambiaríamos la vida de esa persona y de
toda su familia
le voy a contar un poco mi historia yo
soy el menor de cuatro hermanos
y en mi casa pasaba algo raro
pablo
el segundo vivir a 100 km de casa
y nosotros íbamos a visitarlos
periódicamente y siempre hacíamos la
misma rutina
damos un paseo en auto después si vamos
a la misma estación de servicio que lo
llevábamos al baño y como él le
encantaba comer helados nos íbamos
siempre a la misma heladería
eso helado lo comían rapidísimo
y adivinen en el lado de quien miraba
cuando terminaba el de él
el de juan su hermano diez años menor y
atacaba
suele tenido un respeto a robaron
ay empecé
a entender
desde la mirada un chiquito que tenía mi
hermano era entre comillas una
enfermedad llamada autismo
eso sucedió durante 12 años
cuando muere mi padre
ahí en la única vez que a mi hermano le
escuché decir una palabra papá
fue un momento muy difícil
pero como cuando unos se van otros
vienen y empezaron a llegar sobrinos
1 2 3
hasta que antes de llegar a la octava la
octava sobrina nací anita
la que me hizo padre mi reina
a los 3 años nació un titán
santi
es que venía a revolucionarlo todo
el que viene a sacar el reinado anita
a los 10 meses de nacido santín viene mi
hermana que psicóloga y me dice con mamá
estuvimos hablando y vemos algo raro en
sant y santi no se sienta sant y no mira
a los ojos porque no lo vas a ver a
marcelo un pediatra amigo de la familia
entonces lo llevamos a santi
y
nos revisa
y lo ve con retraso madurativo y con
hipotonía
y ahí recuerdo que cuando tenía 20 días
a él no se le caía del cordón umbilical
entonces le había hecho un análisis de
sangre y le había dado mal
pero la doctora había dicho que no había
que hacer nada
entonces este nuevo pediatra le mando
hasta todos los análisis y ese parámetro
volvió a dar mal era que tenía
hipotiroidismo
desde ahí lo empezaron a medicar
y empezó con estimulación temprana
ha estimulado la avenida varias veces
por semana mi casa y le hacía hacer una
serie de ejercicios de rodar
en unos rodillos y en unas pelotas
y todos esos ejercicios lo teníamos que
hacer nosotros después cuando ella no
estaba cosas que santi odiaban
pero con el tiempo
sandy se sentó
y después empezó a batear
teníamos que empujarles los límites
siempre un poquito más porque cuando
todos los chicos avanzaban a 10 sancti
no si a 1
después
empezó a tener una batería de terapias
psicología psicomotricidad
fonoaudiología musicoterapia y todas las
terapias que se imaginen
en un momento surgió algo nuevo hay que
hacer floor time que es tratar de
conectar con tu hijo a través de la
mirada
entonces
me tenía que tirar al piso jugar ahí
sacaba toda mi vocación de arquitecto
hacíamos ciudades increíbles con bloques
pistas autistas todos los días
por qué
una persona con autismo no es que te
está ignorando está está esperando a que
vos te conecte con su mundo
pero esto
me decían que yo no tenía que hacer ocho
veces por día cosa que era imposible
a los 34 años vamos a ver al neurólogo
y nos dice
lo que santiago tiene es un trastorno
generalizado del desarrollo que es un
síndrome del espectro autista
hasta ahí
la sombra
de entre comillas de enfermedad de mi
hermano no existía
después
le pusieron una terapia
cognitivo-conductual
porque mi casa
en un caos
gobernada por un niño que tenía la casa
invadida de juguetes entonces empezaron
a abrir a casa un montón de terapeutas y
llenaron toda la casa de las
consecuencias de dibujitos de cómo ir al
baño cómo comer cómo vestirse
y de a poco los fueron ordenando a él ya
toda la familia
de tanto ir a terapias yo veía
en la calle no había muchos chicos como
santi
y eso que santi se hace notar
yo creo que la discapacidad se la cargan
las madres en la espalda hay muchos
padres
que no lo aceptan hasta les llega a dar
vergüenza no se dan cuenta que se pueden
divertir con sus hijos
hay momentos difíciles cuando un chico
tiene un berrinche la calle cuándo
porque le molestan los ruidos en lugares
nuevos
pero los chicos hay que empujar los
límites porque no es
y esos miedos se le vayan a ir
pero sí que los empiecen a tolerar
en un momento nos dijeron que santi le
faltaba tonicidad a los músculos como
cuando era bebé y ahí me explicaron bien
que era falta de tonicidad
entonces
lo primero que pensé es hay que entrenar
entonces compré un triciclo con ruedas
anchas
y nos llevamos a chapadmalal en el
verano y pedal y hagamos vueltas y
vueltas
por las calles de ripio
y
desde ahí nunca más dejó de pedalear
volvió con las piernas bien fuertes de
ahí pasamos un karting a una bicicleta
con rueditas
hasta que en un momento las revistas se
estalla van por su peso entonces me fui
a la bicicletería y le dije cuál es el
siguiente paso para aprender a andar en
bicicleta y me dicen tenemos este caño
que actúa como
las escobas cuando nos enseñaban a andar
cuando no las chiquitos
y entonces empieza a salir con eso le
saco una ruedita para intentar que se
largue solo y no lo lograba yo antes
caminaba ahora empezaba a trotar con él
agarrándolo hasta que un día tuve que
sacar la otra ruedita porque no había
manera y ahí empecé a correr a su lado
ahí era donde santi empujaba mis límites
a mí me gusta correr pero lo tuve que
hacer durante un año y medio
como tampoco lograba soltarlo solo
pensé tenemos que poner una fuerte
motivación y ahí le dije a sus 7 años
santín
cuando tengas 15 vamos a ir a cruzar la
cordillera
se veía lindo no
y el tiempo es tanto corre a su lado
logró salir solo
ah y nos divertimos durante varios años
salíamos peleamos por el verano
por casa en invierno siempre parada
obligada al kiosco
y
hasta que en un momento es fue creciendo
me ven a mí el pinta igual
xavi brazo empezaba a donar
y el sueño de la cordillera
se veía cada vez más lejos
hasta que un día
en el colegio de anita un guía de
turismo viene y se presenta
como guía de turismo de aventura
entonces declaró
y medio tengo un proyecto con mi hijo
que tiene autismo que es cruzar la
cordillera de los andes
pero hay un pequeño detalle no sabe
frenar
y me dice yo cruce la cordillera con una
persona ciega como en un tándem
y qué es eso una bicicleta de 2 y ahí
recordé
cuando en mi infancia de haber visto
alguna
entonces pensé
y pensé
donde consigo un tándem y la ciudad de
las bicicletas raras es miramar créanlo
fuimos a miramar alquilamos el tándem y
los llevamos a chapadmalal en auto
y perderíamos durante todo el verano
aprendimos a hacerlo y a divertirnos en
él
al año siguiente repetimos hicimos lo
mismo pero no podíamos hacer muchos
kilómetros porque era pesado e incómodo
hace un año y siete meses encontré la
bicicletería que nos iba a ser nuestro
tándem
hice una vaquita entre amigos y familia
y compramos el tándem
desde ese día
nos vestimos de negro
como un equipo
como el mejor equipo
como si fuera menos all blacks
y desde ahí ya hicimos 5000 km
y daríamos a 4000 metros por la quebrada
de humahuaca
por la quebrada de cafayate olavarría
y en cada pedaleada
vuelve el sueño de cruzar la cordillera
hay un momento
en el cual yo lo llamo de felicidad
absoluta lo máximo
y cuando santiago
pone sus manos en mi espalda
y empieza a jugar me hace masajes
mínimos empieza a cantar la escala
musical mejor no canto yo
a contar 1 2 3
y lo peor que eso pasa cuando vamos 30
km
todos los fines de semana
le daríamos 80 kilómetros como modo de
entrenamiento para cruzar los andes
y cuando llegamos
yo le digo santi sos un campeón y es lo
primero que me dices
viví
para ver cuando volvemos a salir a
pedalear muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]